says his home is like a prison with
raised walls and barbed wire
he describes the time when he and his
family were nearly killed after Israeli
settlers threw a petrol bomb into his
house
that was 20 years ago Bart's attacks by
those living illegally further up the
valley in the occupied West Bank haven't
stopped since
last week was the fourth time he says
Israeli settlers set one of his cars on
fire and like thousands of Palestinians
have been regularly targeted he won't be
receiving any compensation
we have full insurance but our case
won't be considered as settler attacks
aren't covered it's costing us a lot no
one from the government has come to
assess the damage either we can't live
like this
Israeli settlers
a town that same day in the worst such
violence in years it led to
International outrage but people here
say they haven't received any of the one
hundred thousand dollars promised by the
Palestinian Authority and it wouldn't be
enough to cover the costs activists say
that attack highlights a lack of
consumer protection laws and the need
for a long-term solution business
we have a social responsibility we live
under occupation we call on the
government to introduce special policy
reforms for the industry to compensate
those that have lost their cars to
settlers violence Financial profits
cannot be more important than
Palestinian lies platform insurance
companies in the occupied West Bank
don't cover damage caused by Israeli
settler or military raids
we're not shirking off responsibility
we're working within International laws
there have been times that exceptional
cases were covered through a private
social responsibility fund but it's up
to the government and civil
organizations to come together with an
alternative we're open to discussion
the Palestinian government hasn't
responded to our requests for an
interview it's reportedly creating a new
committee to look into the hawara attack
but there appears to be no plan to
tackle The Wider problem
now every Palestinian family we've
spoken to here so they've absolutely
reached Breaking Point the financial
losses because of settler attacks are
increasing year on year and they said
that it's had a massive toll well not
only their mental but also physical
health
next to mosab is a pile of rocks held at
them by settlers living at the top of
the hill feeling abandoned he says he's
been left with no choice but to fend for
himself
Al Jazeera burin Village in occupied
West Bank